hi there steve kaufman here i'm in the
old town here in bratislava in the main
square it's about 8 10 in the morning
what do you think i'm doing i'm out
jogging and listening to my check
putting in the time but i'm also here to
run out something as much as i'm
enjoying my check i'm going to undertake
a new challenge and i want you to join
me we call it the 90-day challenge i'm
going to spend 90 days learning korean
or at least taking my korean up to a new
level because i've kind of dabbled in
korean here and there off and on or
about five or six years and i'm not
happy at my level and i know that in
language learning while it's a long road
it requires intensity so i'm going to
commit for 90 days to study with
intensity i'm going to v-log like i'm
doing now getting into the habit of
using my
iphone to shoot short snippets i'm going
to report daily on what i'm doing how i
gather resources how i develop habits
that enable me to stay intense and i
want you to join me i want you to follow
it
on my blog at my youtube channel
and share with us what you're doing
because intensity for some people who
have a lot of time might be five six
hours a day it might be one hour a day
but it means creating new habits
staying with them
and working with more intensity than we
are used to
and the reason i can do this is kind
because i know from experience that it
works i know that i'm going to improve i
know that i'm going to take my korean
from a level where i can barely
understand what people are saying up to
a high level so go for it everyone a
little cold here go for it
bye for now and join us in the 90 day
challenge